what does story structure mean to you
story structure for me is uh
it's essential and yet at the same time
i
i try to ignore it if that makes sense
it's i mean
you know with all the stuff i've talked
a bit about kind of liking to defy
conventions or whatever
but i also do believe that as an artist
if you don't understand what those
conventions are
what the structures are then you're not
defining them you just don't know what
you're doing
if you don't follow them and so i really
did spend
you know read about it a lot and i've
you know studied in terms like story
structure and the
you know the three act the fire back
structure all that type of stuff
there's such a value to it i mean even
if it's
not obvious that it's there in a lot of
films it should
kind of be there and so i do follow that
like this one i feel like has like the
traditional
five act structure just in a very loose
way
um and it's just
you know if you don't hit certain plot
points by certain points you're going to
bore your audience uh you know it's one
thing to challenge an audience and to
ask them to really commit themselves to
your story it's another to
you know force them to you know wait
forever for something to happen
or to not give them something to cling
on to narratively
so i do try to keep the audience's
interest and attention at my in their in
my mind when i'm
maybe not the first draft but as i'm
editing and refining the script i like
to keep that audience uh
perspective in mind like okay they have
to watch this so let me think about them
now
uh and so that's where i think knowing
the structure really comes into
play is just knowing knowing the best
way to
reach those beats hit those moments uh
i did say earlier though i'm not a big
fan of character arcs at least not
obvious ones because i feel like in real
life
unless something traumatic happens to
you you don't actually
change you just adjust or um
so for me instead of worrying about a
character arc like well he starts here
and he ends
this person where he finds this out of
himself and changes here
i kind of like to create a personality
type
and a psychology and then put them into
a situation like okay now how do they
cope with this
what is that's kind of more how we are
in real life is
you know i am who i am if you put me in
a burning building i'm not going to
suddenly turn into a hero i'm probably
going to flee
um you know what circumstances
would it take for me to become that hero
it would have to be for a loved one my
cats depended on the day maybe i would
risk it
but you know that's to me is the
interesting thing is not necessarily
like
hitting the ark in the traditional way
but setting those plot points of like
okay at this point
this character has this happened to him
and
he does this and then at this point he
realizes oh
this all backfired and then it you know
so that's kind of how i like to follow
the structure like you have those points
but in terms like so much of the
traditional writing on
story structure and everything i'm not a
fan of a lot of the guidance on how
stories should develop
you know obviously there's some very
very successful filmmakers that have
followed those formulas and done quite
well with it so
you know take my my opinion on it for
what it's worth
uh i'm on my second film we'll see how
it do how it does
so but that's at least how i approach it
personally
you